[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros en 5
minutos con hoy analizaremos las
prácticas productivas empresariales que
se han adquirido durante la pandemia de
kobe 19 y que se debería seguir haciendo
después de la crisis sanitaria nos
acompaña diego rosero gerente general de
epson colombia gracias señor rosero por
estar con nosotros cuáles son los
avances que se han logrado con la
implementación del teletrabajo que tanto
es bueno o no el trabajo remoto para una
empresa y como ha hecho su compañía
muy bien buenos días muchas gracias por
la invitación mira esto fue un cambio
radical en colombia teníamos 120.000
personas en teletrabajo y en menos de un
mes pasamos a tres millones y medio
entonces eso implicó unos cambios
fundamentales en los procesos de
adaptación el resultado ha sido muy
positivo se aumentó la productividad se
aumentó el manejo del cómo se manejan y
controlan los recursos también se
lograron muchas deficiencias y muchos
sabores importantes porque se cambiaron
muchos paradigmas en el tema de las
reuniones y los viajes de negocios
también pero hay que verlo por el otro
lado porque hay que ver las dos aristas
siempre de la moneda seguro de harvard
mini review
la carga laboral aumenta un 20 por
ciento es decir que nosotros como
empresarios estamos felices del aumento
de la productividad pero por otro lado
los los dos colaboradores pues tienen
algunas situaciones porque dicen que
están trabajando en horarios mucho más
extendidos de los que tenían antes
cuando estaban en la oficina entonces
hay que saber combinar estas dos
situaciones entre
la productividad y respetar los espacios
personales y laborales en la casa bien
señor rosero y qué tecnologías
emergentes se encuentran en boga para
las empresas y cómo aportan en el
crecimiento del negocio
en tecnología obviamente la más
implantada más importante han sido todo
lo que tiene que ver con las
herramientas de videoconferencias y de
accesos remotos también se ha generado
un crecimiento exponencial en todas las
herramientas informáticas en la casa
computadores impresoras escáner incluso
bio proyectores para hacer las
conferencias mucho más interactivas
pero lo que lo que ha generado esto
estas tecnologías y los retos más
grandes al tema de la ciberseguridad
porque no todos estamos preparados para
tener los mismos niveles de seguridad en
la casa que teníamos en las empresas eso
ha generado un reto importante para las
compañías pero yo creo que estamos
estamos listos en este proceso hemos
avanzado en esta situación lo que lo que
desarrollo digital se demoró diez años
en hacer en estas ocho semanas lo
logramos entonces creo que el balance ha
sido positivo y la tecnología ha sido
facilitador porque el hogar se convirtió
el centro de la productividad el centro
de estudios el centro de la diversión
entonces la tecnología ha sido
protagonista en cada uno de los aspectos
profundicemos por favor más en este tema
que ya no se identificaba como el de
seguridad que otros retos tecnológicos
han surgido durante la pandemia
los restos han sido muy grandes pero es
lo que me parece importante llamar la
atención de que toda la tarde otra
formación digital las compañías con un
foco muy grande en toda la inversión
tecnológica y de seguridad
infraestructura pero hay una parte
importante porque la trasformación
tecnológica pasa por unos cambios y esos
cambios tienen que ver con el manejo de
la parte de la parte emocional de la
parte psicológica de las personas que
buscan generar una de un momento a otro
incertidumbre ansiedad
falta de conocimientos y también el tema
del aislamiento entonces ves que las
compañías tienen que ser una muy buena
combinación entre el invertir en
infraestructura tecnológica de equipo de
software de seguridad pero también en
ofrecerle a los colaboradores espacios y
herramientas para que no pierdan esa
parte de interacción social esa parte de
interacción personal que ayuda en el
desarrollo también de la creatividad en
aumentar la productividad no sé qué ser
el balance entre la inversión en
tecnología y la inversión en
herramientas para que la gente manejes
muy bien sus emociones en este momento
de tanta incertidumbre y tanta ansiedad
que se debería seguir haciendo después
de la crisis sanitaria señor rosero y
cuál es el futuro del trabajo en la
novedad
y con la experiencia del teletrabajo que
ha dejado la pandemia yo creo que las
canciones que antiguas un esquema
híbrido de las compañías ya han logrado
definir cuáles son los cargos que son
100 por ciento que se pueden hacer por
teletrabajo y cuáles requieren un modelo
de presencialidad entonces se maneja
esquema se va a manejar esquema híbrido
donde las compañías batman van a tener
ese ese proceso también el otro de los
avances importantes es mantener las
eficiencias que hemos logrado en este
tiempo porque el foco más grande que
hemos tenido las las compañías es como
como mantenemos el punto de equilibrio
ante el impacto que hemos tenido en los
temas de demanda entonces es el reto es
mantener el esquema en el cual
el trabajador esté satisfecho esté
conforme y la compañía obtenga los
mejores los mejores recursos en este
nuevo escenario nos quedan veinte
segundos nada más para hablar el aporte
tecnológico para la educación
para la tecnología es fundamental con la
que la educación no pare pero la reto
más grande ha sido cómo se mantiene y
con qué herramientas de lograr la
interacción y que sea metodologías que
permitan esa esa parte interactiva
dinámica pues el resto también ha sido
para los dos y si la tecnología ha
soportado la comunicación la tecnología
ha soportado todo el proceso para que la
educación no se pare si bien pues muchas
gracias ya lo interrumpí pero muchas
gracias por esta comunicación su
compresión diego rosero gerente general
de epson colombia hacía con nosotros en
francés 24
[Música]